I've got some new tour dates to announce
right now April 25th
at the celebrity theater in Phoenix
Arizona
we're adding a date onto that week March
23rd we've added in Houston Texas
uh that's a Thursday night at The Hobby
Lobby Center for the Performing Arts May
10th Newark New Jersey New Jersey Center
for the Performing Arts May 11th
Westbury New York at the New York CB
theater at Westbury
June 9th Austin we've added another
Austin show and June 30th and July 2nd
Las Vegas at the Encore Theater wow I
can't believe it man
oh I just can't even believe that uh
that we're getting to do all this
this is crazy thank you uh it's at
theovan.com
t-o-u-r you have to go through those
links to get accurately priced tickets
if you're elsewhere that's out of our
control
you know um there's already a lot of
monsters there on the internet with
these ticketing fees and those are out
of our control as well but uh I love you
guys and um and I hope to get to see you
if you can come out we now have be good
to yourself crewnecks available in light
blue maroon and cement that embankment
gang color you know it check these out
along with the new windbreaker at
theovinstore.com and thank you for your
support
today's guest is a Entertainer a
comedian uh producer actor
he's a creative
and um and he's kind of like a universe
in a way you know you you meet him and
you meet the people that are in his
Circle and it's just man it's a uh it's
a very entertaining world uh I'm happy
to have him here today my friend drewski
[Music]
sit and tell you about stories
oh foreign
[Music]
50 Cent 50 kids
we got the [__] orphans
God dang huh he's sick he's been feeding
y'all
I'm just saying man I'm just glad you
came through man yeah I know it this is
the damn Underground Railroad for us
cause we needed some brothers up in here
man
yeah y'all definitely needed some black
people up in there I was looking for a
black episode I swear it took me a
minute I was looking though I was
definitely looking for a black episode
I'm scrolling man you gotta scroll for a
while we almost had to call Donnell
Rollins in again bro he's everybody's
go-to uh pot podcast no you had you did
have one older black guy it was like uh
he was like a politician or something oh
oh yeah who was that yeah it was
something we have Miss Pat in hmm so
Miss Pat that was good and then oh we
had Neil deGrasse Tyson bro
I don't know who the [__] that is that's
space brother dog you believe it who's
that bring him up Zach Neil deGrasse
Tyson let's rock
we recording yeah yeah
that Neil deGrasse Tyson man we had him
in he's like that there he is oh yeah
that old dude he kind of looked he
resembled uh Michael Jackson died oh
yeah he don't he dude he do don't it Joe
Jackson real Jackson pull up Joe Jackson
let's see some damn Joe Jackson and Neil
deGrasse Tyson yeah because Neil will
beat the [__] out of some space stats
back in the day Joe back in the day Joe
you guys yeah fresh joke because this is
damn yeah this ball joke ball sector
right here that ain't the new Joe he's
trying to look like that third yeah man
you know damn bro he's going through it
though man it's a legendary family
though is it yeah yeah did you ever get
to meet Michael Jackson ah damn it man I
wish I did though you know that was what
[__] 10 when he died damn that would
have been the time to meet him yeah yeah
sad times though you know King of Pop
yeah I was at I was on stage one time
and he pulled up in the alley outside of
the window and uh
you you have seen Michael Jackson yeah I
saw him like you've seen him I've
officially saw him outside of a second
story window he was going into the uh
costume shop
it was at night and it was closed but
they opened it up for him and he pulled
up and
a song kind of get out
and he got out all [__] like he just
looked like he was just
like he barely [__]
like he just got out you know like he
just kind of like was out you know he
didn't have to really do a lot yeah it
seemed like he just wasn't there wasn't
a lot to him you know he was very like
he's a fragile person he's very fragile
yeah yeah he looked fragile man uh how
tall was Michael Jackson
of course huh
that is a good question I have no clue
how tall Michael Jackson I never thought
about how there's a Frills like uh five
foot nine
problem that's that's kind of small bro
yeah yeah he's a smaller guy damn yeah
because he started looking Asian at the
end huh he switched up we made a big
switch up he went through all he went
every he didn't [__] miss a gender he
didn't miss her ethnicity
oh man he hit them all for real then he
went past white like the white he went
was like that's what the [__] wife is
like we're like oh he's the one that did
slavery bro we were all pointing at him
we're like that [__] did it bruh
we were pointing at him dude he looked
like Jackie O at the end bro pull up
Jackie oh man
dang cause he went all the way right
dang bro you know his dad was beating
the [__] out of them though oh he's
beating the [__] out that's probably
what his dad looked like that now like a
damn ball sack but a lot of black guys
can sing anyway it's like why would you
even beat your kid in a singer yeah yeah
but he was talented I think he just
wanted them to be perfect though you
know yeah yeah damn bro
so sometimes you get Excellence out of
that though yeah yeah
I wonder if people you could beat
somebody in the Excellence maybe that's
an example of it that's an example but
you know they they lose their mind after
it you know
so it's it's it's a bad Trail just it's
downhill Trail man it's sad I'm friends
with his daughter she's
awesome champ Janet Jackson no Paris
Jackson who the [__] is that oh Michael
Jackson's daughter yeah are you real
yeah
she's a sweetheart wow
um where's blanket can we where's
blanket blanket baby blanket baby
blanket disappeared right oh I don't
know I think he changed his name and
everything oh really yeah oh yeah yeah I
don't think Blanket Jackson is
[__] throw rug or something
you look different blanket is like a
because a lot of brothers used to have
crazy names back in the day blanket
whisker yeah you meet his brother named
he changed his name didn't he damn he
kind of had that Native American look
wow did Michael Jackson use his own nut
to make his kids
couldn't have you mean into a woman he'd
look Indian yeah there's no way that
there ain't no black gene or not he
looked like full moon wall yeah yeah
yeah
no black Jean in that blood right there
you know yeah but that's a good question
right I think even if Paris Jackson how
does she look she's completely white
right she has more of a white look she
has a little bit I think she gets you
can see a little bit of
um like
there you go
yeah you know ain't no black in that
book I don't know she got a little bit
Urban in the eyes I think in my eyes I
think so they're [__] blue yeah but
they [__] want to be black
oh how do they want to be black you can
see look in the Mitch zoom in Zach dang
come on man let's see guessing
yeah nah that's I don't see any black
there man other than the pupils yeah
that's a little that's about it yeah
he didn't make that with his nut man I'm
telling you I don't know that's funny
yet because I guess if you are not
because I don't know if he was attracted
to I guess he was attracted to women huh
yeah yeah yeah but who knows you know
yeah it's Michael Jackson yeah dude he
probably did a lot of secret stuff
drewski thanks for coming bro thank you
brother thank you for having me good to
see you man um so for some of my
audience that doesn't know you there may
be some that doesn't know you which uh
you know would be rare but so I just
want to know a little bit where you got
started at man
um you know before we met before we were
friends man I was just
just grinding it out man I've naturally
been a funny guy my whole life you know
[__] you know hey man
I've told the story 50 times have you
[__] it there man okay but just say a
place man yeah all right well uh I was
born in Maryland oh damn bro Maryland
baby dang cuz
Maryland bruh I feel like you're nigging
it up for me he's like yeah
that's great that's crazy good
yeah you gotta do some dance next dude
I'm just saying bruh I get it now I
moved I moved to Atlanta Georgia at one
so oh damn you got there early huh yeah
yeah I got about it you beat the rush
man yeah yeah yeah dude cause Maryland
man it gets [__] if you Baltimore
you're from Baltimore yeah Baltimore's
Baltimore's wild bro red please red
place for real dude uh from a place like
Columbia like type area yeah yeah
Baltimore is a good place to get oysters
and murdered that's what I always say
bro
[Laughter]
but they'll smoke Rock but with a
lobster bib on bro you gotta respect
that [__] man you'll see a dude smoking
out of a bread bowl you know what I'm
saying
[Music]
nah dude it's good look man I don't get
to be around a lot of black folks I'm
happy that you're here man I figured
that's what I wanted to do the episode I
didn't I told you I was looking and I
just couldn't find any black you know
Black Talent being interviewed price I
guess I'll be the uh the
guess I'll be the first guy to do
something yeah bro thank you man
thank you bro
um what's going on man uh working on
this tour man getting ready for this
tour yeah so tell me about this are you
doing stand-up on it or what's it like
I've seen some clips but what is it like
and is that hard on you when you go out
there yeah I think it's a lot of
pressure a lot of people want to know if
I'm gonna do stand up a lot of people
you know the ogs I've talked to I don't
know if I'm gonna do stand up uh just
giving the fans what they want man when
they come on this tour they're gonna see
you I haven't given out too much what
I'm gonna do on this team yeah that's
why even when we come very interesting
when we spoke about it it was kind of
it's a comedy show though it's not like
[__] right and so who else is on the
tour with you I know you got a huge name
uh yeah no no we don't we didn't put too
many big names it's just me
um we have an opener but it's undecided
right now so we're in like the process
of seeing it's definitely a comedian
that will do stand-up uh as an opener
but we're seeing right now it's just
gonna be uh
it's gonna be a great show man and I and
I'm super excited I have like all the
emotions like I'm excited you know
nervous uh [__] you know going
through it every night in my head
thinking about what this [__] looks like
you know this is my first Tour by myself
other tours I've gone on I've opened up
for other people you know so oh maybe
that's what I was looking at I knew you
were doing your own but I think I saw
something you were working with you were
doing with I don't know if it was
musicians right was there one you were
doing uh I opened up on J Cole and
um Chris Brown's tour before yeah so did
that feel kind of hard because you could
walk I mean you're walking out there
there's 20 000 people out there you know
whatever you know a lot of a lot of I
was surprised a lot of the people love
me like they I was going out there like
no material just you know [__] with
the crowd and going out there just
improv [__] with the crowd I think it
was it was great experience but um yeah
now it's time for me to show my talent
off to my fans because I've been doing
this for like
six years and I haven't done anything
for my fans I've done some meet and
greets and stuff but nothing to
entertain my own fans that I I built up
to this point you know so yeah yeah dang
same with you man you know we went on
the trip to Louisiana you were telling
me about how you you only like to do you
know small shows and if you were able to
do big shows that you probably wouldn't
even do it yeah I mean I don't know why
you said that that kind of threw me off
what was the reason why not because I
like to know that they got like I like
to almost be able to see the guy in the
back of the room so I can get an idea if
he's having a good time or not I feel
like if you get above like third like 3
000 in a place you can't really tell
yeah if that guy in the back like so I
would rather do like four if I could
sell like in Baton Rouge we sold I mean
I think we sold like 8 000 tickets so
you'll do it you just don't enjoy the
big big big ones right because it feels
like uh I don't know for some reason I
think I feel like a little bit selfish
about it I don't know I feel like I want
to give them a better shot you want the
people in the back to enjoy it just like
the [__] yeah yeah I get it I
get it yeah so and I think like it's and
if you don't have screens and stuff like
then in a smaller Vin you don't really
have to have screens so then I don't
know if you always feel like it's a
little bit of a disconnect if somebody's
watching the screen I don't know same I
actually uh requested screens on this
toy that I'm doing because it's theater
so I requested screens to be on both
sides maybe even in the middle just so
you can see my facial expressions yeah
it's important yeah because that all
that matters with the jokes I get what
you're saying are they are you doing
pretty big places yeah well theaters
yeah like about 7K yeah you need screens
for that yeah for sure I I haven't even
seen how big that is yet I haven't you
know nothing feels big yeah yeah yeah is
are you gonna have others you said
somebody's gonna open up for you you're
gonna have uh yeah so right now we're
looking at two different comedians I
didn't I didn't want to get anybody you
know that didn't fit like
you know the genre of my type of Comedy
so it was kind of peculiar it's kind of
peculiar of what we're looking for here
and I mean nobody's me but you know I'll
try to figure out what my fans enjoy
yeah the type of Comedy so we're looking
at two cats right now man dang huh
you're gonna make them really go at it
yeah yeah
we might bring both of them on so we'll
see we'll see damn it's gonna be
exciting though [__] demon home baby
what you know about that maybe I'll
watch that video so many times I cannot
it's like that's like a video for the
Black Culture I don't know why people
watch that video
no
no are they ready that little Ray man
this thing right now all right
that little rain I love you what
man right cold on the field
the demon home too [__] you know why
people be tuned into something right
little right now that's a little Ray
wait what do you have any people that
have gone to jail before did you relate
to that video yeah I just loving people
I mean everybody I think loves seeing
black people get out of jail what the
[__] what that's true that's true but we
shouldn't even have been in there in the
first place let's spread that message
[__] I mean that's they got a lot of
opinions on that but I'm just saying I
think if a brother gets out of jail
everybody's like [__] yeah let's get
it bro Tony's home it's like a real even
the whole neighborhood welcome yeah yeah
yeah
but some people actually live on to that
even longer than they should like some
people act like they just got out months
after oh really damn right and living in
this [__] which is stupid they put bars
in her bedroom yeah like that not
institutionalized is is a real thing man
like I even did a video on now I don't
know if you saw that like um
I know some people I have a friend his
brother's institutionalized and he
literally his brother literally wakes up
and like it feels like he's still in
prison like wakes up at like 5 a.m has
his [__] toothbrush
uh shoes everything you put out but not
even in the bathroom like literally in
the weirdest places like right next to
the bed yeah or like folded up like the
every every white shirt is color
coordinated rolled up next to the so
it's a it's a real thing like and they
waking up at the time that they would be
waking up in prison damn and like just
waking up doing [__] ironing just
cleaning [__] like very they're always
very clean though Instagram a lot of
people they always very like are they
are they good are they are is it like uh
if you see an institutionalized dude is
it get a little bit scary or yeah not
it's it's they're cool but they
they literally are like
I don't know how to explain it man like
they they like their stuff is they stuff
right don't [__] with this stuff like
the smallest thing could be this could
be his [__] yeah
and this might be looking like a million
[__] dollars
we'll bite your hand off for this [__]
yeah you know what I'm saying like
really like it's that's how it is with
an institutionalized family and he'll
have like a little fan he'll have like
he carved his family out of like a
Saltine crack or something he'll have
that bit propped up by the bed but it's
a little [__] like that like it's just
it's weird bro like oh you know but I I
always thought [__] like that was funny
because two yeah so many people go home
and came home bro God damn bro oh yeah
and they dropped his [__]
foreign
how they make those videos when people
get out and the first thing they do is
put them off
and a lot of them have had like years to
think up a couple bars or something and
they say the [__] dummies you know
I'm gonna kill everybody some dude said
I was like dang bro
so
Freedom boys though man free the real
ones yeah dude I think it's uh yeah I
don't know I guess hey yeah
I guess it's I don't know as many folks
that have gone to prison really
you know I mean I would I guess I would
like to know more of them yeah you know
where are you from again I'm from
Louisiana oh well you should [__] you
should know something we had to depend
on what part though yeah I'm from like
uh just north of New Orleans about an
hour so it was just like a black and
white area yeah what did we have this
country is on some country [__] no it
wasn't redneck it was just like kind of
poor oh damn poor my area is like poor
white and poor black and then they had
like
uh some wealthier people but they wasn't
that wealthy they just seem wealthy you
know like they had a [__] garage
people around you nobody was really
really wealthy oh no bro no no no no no
dude it was [__] you said a garage
would be like yeah like we had a bus
driver dude he picked us up one day and
he didn't take us to [__] school bro
this dude Milford he just drove us
around and about 30 minutes into it
we're like [__] we ain't even going to
school bro I'm taking y'all to do
something weird
just driving I think he's trying to stay
away from his wife really and uh I think
why not just take you all to school
that wasn't on his mind man
he had different [__] on his mind and
look his name is Milford his name is
Milford bro
and he had uh a mixed child he had a
mixed child named Boogie and because he
would but he pretended like it was him
and his white wife's child but it was
they had a black lady named Tilly that
sweeped out his school bus hold up hold
up hold the [__] and they had a job hold
the whole story
a black maybe a black lady named Tilly
yeah
[Music]
look at you I got you
but bro the crazy [__] was he tried to
tell everybody it was him and his wife's
child right because he didn't want
nobody to know that he'd been messing
around you know and uh so they would
dress him up in Western [__] to make him
look whiter they would make him wear
like boots and like a little cowboy hat
and uh and so he would look like as
white as possible you know and so they
always had him like he would always just
kind of you know
just doing like all of this little start
off a little bit yeah I guess he was
bruh but it was just interesting you
know it was just kind of different times
man
he was able yeah you you from a
different time where they could do that
type of stuff yeah I don't know yeah I
guess they were I mean there was no
slavery going on it was just who the
hell said that about me I'm not saying
those times oh yeah no it was yeah yeah
no I'm I'm no I'm saying like toms were
like kids weren't really giving a [__]
about it around the time oh yeah Curry
kids weren't good yeah it was just like
yeah it was all type of [__] going on oh
bruh yeah but now it's like you can't
even spank your kids man yeah nowadays
kid I mean I feel like yeah when I was
young everybody was getting molested or
[__] [__] that [__] was just like
that must deep
and uh nowadays I feel like a kid
wouldn't even notice if you molested
them they so busy on the Kindle you know
oh yeah
see a Kindle I mean on the screen just
like you can't even get a book reading
[__] yeah you can't even get a kid's
attention it's so busy on the console
man you know that's that's dark man is
it
cheers cheers
oh
wow
I was talking about spanking kids bro
you went to molest station man I'm just
trying to make conversation bro how is
that a conversation starter I don't know
man my bad what the [__] that's like the
worst conversation starter ever
kids do a lot of [__] you're right
they're great man you're right it's like
the worst thing that could happen to a
kid other than murder
[__] y'all [__] up
y'all [__] up
this dude's sick and ain't trying to put
it on y'all you hear him I'm just saying
y'all [__] up man yeah man that's it
dude roses are red violets are blue and
our friends at manscaped have a gift for
you that's right the leader in grooming
has revolutionized their men's hygiene
game once again with the new beard
hedger Pro kit whoo
this cordless trimmer has a rotary wheel
with 20 hair cutting lengths all in one
guard
so no more messy drawers full of extra
add-ons and even better save 20 off and
free shipping
by going to manscape.com and using Code
Theo that's right it's Valentine's Day
and you want to shape up
that uh
that chin Garden baby you want to groom
up
that cheek Forest Homie Get Right and
get well and look dang decent for your
lover
so get 20 off in free shipping with code
Theo at manscape.com that's 20 off with
free shipping at manscape.com and use
code Theo
spice up this v-day
with manscaped beard hedger one stroke
one guard 20 lengths
um do you ever run across Boosie in
Atlanta or no no I wish I did Boosie we
tried to get Boosie on the show he taxed
us bro he did I thought it was gonna do
it just on some like some black love
[__] you know some Brotherhood [__] but
no I think how much he tried to uh get
us to pay him
so how much boost you try to get us to
pay him
oh y'all paid them
twenty twenty thousand damn yeah
huh
yeah I don't know dang we ain't paying
twenty thousand yeah man he tried us wow
yeah did y'all think about it for sure
yeah because you know he's a great guy
to have on we we were doing uh a blind
dating show around that time so we were
bringing on celebrities and like doing
Blind dating bring on like girls you
know yeah but nobody else charged us
except for him and I was like he would
be a great person oh yeah man because I
I salute him because you know you got to
get your money man yeah and he does
everything I think individuals
everything in his world seems kind of a
la card like he doesn't like that he
doesn't trust the big system you know I
think he does everything like literally
even his movies he does all that by
himself in cash you know you know what's
the wildest product you've seen somebody
have man because
I think some people have some wild
products and product you mean like
owning yeah like something like Boosie
has his chips and that's great right
Master P has a chance got the chips I'm
trying to think of something that's
money back yo just started his own water
hmm yeah would you buy money back get
water
um
it's hard for you because
water no I drink water at a black kid's
house [__] off
uh I didn't have a lot yeah yeah I know
uh [__]
um who who got another company that that
is owned man
who owns who owns a company right now
um what about a cologne or something I
feel like they'd have something like I
would I would definitely get into that
for real because I like you smelled the
cologne I had on when I came in there I
don't know you guys smelled good yeah
I feel like you're so full of [__]
really yeah no you guys smelled good man
bro yeah what do we smell like when we
walked up honestly I usually think it's
D like a lot of deodorant
wow
bruh yeah no black people do wear a lot
of deals
you'll see a [__] start at the
wrist bro put that [__] on
somebody put that [__] on so slow like
damn oh my God somebody put this [__]
[__] nah man I was just asking because
you know
we actually did indulge and deodorant
before we got here oh yeah bro
um and drewski would be a great name for
a cologne or Drew Sky oh yeah that's
closer
yeah no I I I I that's something to
think about for real I would love to do
some [__] like that man what would you
do if you wanted to start your own
company I don't know I think I would do
something
Sunday like skateboarding or some [__]
dude I'm not good at that
skateboarding's hard yeah I don't like
that kind of stuff like being like out
of control I think I would do like a uh
maybe a graham cracker or something
that fits you more low-key I love them
[__] though yeah yeah yeah yeah
you'll tear up some graham crackers I
noticed that when we was in Louisiana oh
yeah yeah that's the first yeah I get
into a [__] thing a graham crackers
boy I'll lay on your [__] bed and eat
them [__]
dude that what'd you think we went to
Louisiana we went to the LSU game uh
there's a couple months back and uh what
do you think compared to some other
college like football experiences that
you've been on that you've been to oh
man they had religious time LSU got them
they did man you know what they did you
I saw some of them man you know you
ain't see them you took something no I
don't think I did took something down go
ahead show the uh show the one he took
down show it on camera
yeah I I I'm gonna send you the picture
if I did I didn't remember it
because they gave me my jersey look back
you're talking to that blonde girl at
the little after party man I was the bad
the bat the baddest one that was in them
that's good news for me man I don't know
if you hit though I still no I didn't I
thought you took it down I didn't man
yeah dude what I just got broke I just
had a girl dump me actually for real
yeah whatever she just said she just
she said she wanted she didn't see where
things could go like she wasn't looking
for any kind of exclusive childish type
[__] she's saying childish Oh I thought
I was doing a good job with her yeah but
she said she didn't want any type of
exclusive she told me you like taking
[__] on walks and [__] though oh yeah
[__] I think so man because I feel
like it depends on the type though yeah
depending on what type of girl what type
what's your type I don't know I think
probably tall volleyball Maybe
likes being indoors
likes being outdoors yeah you know likes
uh might have a pet might not I don't
want somebody with two pets honestly bro
you know and I don't know it says it's
too much because you're gonna start
smelling like the pet yeah I [__] with
this girl
uh it's actually a white girl she always
smell like her dog bro she owns this
[__] uh this [__] uh
like a like a like a bulldog and it's
not a bad smell because she used to put
perfume on and [__] but you always gonna
smell that [__] yeah yeah it's it's a
it's like a dog smell you know yeah like
like a wet dog type of smell yeah yeah
but people always say that white people
smell like wet dogs is that an old man
is that true
she might not even have a dog oh damn
it's my dog because I don't know if she
has a dog but she does always
she smells well it smells damp like it's
like a damn smell I don't know but it's
like a smell she gives off every time
she smells like Seattle
[Laughter]
24 7 but she sprays [__] on but just
never get rid of that you know yeah yeah
I'm trying to think man uh
yeah I think I I uh I don't know what
kind I guess I like
I don't know I like
you ever dated a black girl
I went home with one black girl one time
how'd that go
this biker was wild she had like a uh I
like how you said this yeah well
she was it go ahead explain the story
how we go again I want to hear the story
though I want to hear the story she had
a kind of a mirror on her ceiling but it
wasn't like it was like one of those
mirrors they have at like a bus stop
where it's like reflective metal yeah
yeah it like pans around yeah so she had
that [__] on the ceiling dude and I was
re I was [__] nervous bruh the one
that like the like the American twist
around and you could if you're looking
right here you can see it around the
other one yeah a little bit on the yeah
yeah it feels like an oval yeah she had
that thing up on the ceiling man and I
and uh in the corner of the room she had
like one of those coat of arms like you
would see from like the night times or
whatever you know I think she was like
one of those Renaissance Fair sisters
you know and uh
and she [__] had yeah they had like
axes on the one I mean that [__] she
was white you know so she was like as
white as you could get
her black girl bro I swears
so I was ready you know I was [__]
fired up and I remember [__] doing
like this right when I got over there
and
um I was excited but I would date a
black girl man I think uh I definitely
feel more open to it when I was young I
think black girls were a lot more
intimidating because they seemed a lot
more
like confidence
are they yes black women are very
confident and they know they know what
they want they straight up with you like
don't bring that little dick over here
oh damn they want that big ass dick big
dick they want you to throw that dick
over your shoulder like a belt yeah
like a dead fox
[__] rope man like you know like but
that can be intimidating which I get I
understand it yeah I got that kind of I
got a good upper medium deck man I got
uh upper medium is just I got that candy
corn I should build like a candy corn
pull up a candy corn Zach
[Laughter]
that's exactly how it's shaped just like
that candy corn come on get me a candy
corn mate yeah click that one
just damn okay like that baby yeah all
right
so like my shit's shaped like the piece
that lands back on Earth after the
shuttle goes up you know what I'm saying
bro
does that work out good though like
because you know some girls know you
know some girls enjoy different
different [__] man you know that's a
that's a whole thing you know yeah yeah
well at least the good thing about I
think well one one that that's a chode
you know that's a chode no Macho but my
mine is a it's it's there's some there's
a second story to it my [__] ain't no
okay I got a joke oh you do yeah oh dang
boy but not chodes are actually coming
handy yeah chose you know they're big
they the the link thing there right the
link ain't there but the girth
girth like a birthday cake huh yeah like
a birthday cake short and Stumpy but you
know you know some girls they like that
[__] you know yeah like a big butt yeah
yeah yeah
birthday cake is a great description of
a joke
a [__] joke wow
I feel like there's so much pressure for
black guys though because you have to
show up with a big wiener man dog
you have no [__] bro you're black
throw that [__] round your shoulders
[Laughter]
[__] but isn't it is that pressure in
the black community that you as a male
you have to because if you don't have it
what do you do then
agent that's what always
about it bro cause at the end of the day
you gotta you gotta satisfy in some type
of way yeah you gotta satisfied
sometimes so the hips is a real thing I
know you y'all white people probably
don't and I used to using their hips and
[__] y'all like the ram [__] y'all are
[__] y'all put your whole fish in a
[__]
y'all do I watch the [__] porn you
guys are nuts but like yeah man just
just Cruise your way in it just start
using your hips more lately like do that
yeah start getting in that thing man
yeah I think and I feel I feel like you
don't you don't give up advice you'll be
getting in it like that I just beat on
the door
y'all do it till it [__] bleeds like
just just be smooth man use your hips
use those [__] hips man I'm gonna try
more next time yeah for sure I gotta get
yeah I just
I gotta get I gotta I gotta have a
different attitude I think my attitude
sometimes when I get involved in sex is
like all right guys we got it's like oh
it always feels like it's fourth down I
get nervous yeah yeah so my [__] I start
on Fourth [__] down everybody going
deep Bro everybody [__] you know what
I'm saying Terry down there somewhere
because I'm [__] throwing that [__]
down there
so it's not long you just go you don't
have a long duration of time when you
start managing you're already in fourth
quarter when it starts we got one play
dog
[Laughter]
so I got it yeah I think I got a child a
little bit better I think that's so
that's definitely one thing that's
intimidating about black guys is there's
definitely a uh there's definitely a
thing that it seemed like they have
they're gonna be better at sex you know
so then you got to feel like what can I
do now yeah you know yeah yeah but you
know that just come with it man you know
we we but that's probably got to be a
lot of pressure though yeah are there
black guys that are not good at sex uh
it's got to be bro you know uh this is
girls out there that talk about dudes
and got [__] huge [__] I can't do
[__] with it you know what I'm saying
they're just [__] loading it up in
there just like just feeding it in there
yeah and they're hurting them you know
so it depends on how you use it that's
why I'm a big Motion in the ocean guy
yeah I'm big on that yeah yeah I like
the preacher you like Magellan out there
huh yeah you're like oh this is hard to
starboard yeah
move the cells
so they already know what I'm coming
with I started preaching that [__]
the second you put on that captain's hat
they know bro they're like put on a hat
you're like yeah I'm telling you man nah
but you know yeah at the end of the day
bro being black is is a great thing man
that's what I wanted to come on to this
podcast and talk about thanks man yeah
you think I could do it do it Be Blood
yeah in the future
do I have what it takes or not
[__] no but I'll tell you what man come
on bro you've done some great things in
life but [__] no
but look man you know you've got you got
hope man like I said Motion in the ocean
uh all that pounding [__] cut it out
right yeah just
yeah it's hard for me to relax man when
I get in there you know yeah it's like
get in there
um I always envied about black people is
that they have like the best origin
story like they have the [__] you
know what I'm talking about like they
have the [__] like yeah you get a
[__] reason made it from the bottom
yeah like you get a [__] when you
wake up you have a reason in you yeah
yeah and that's one thing I always was
like real envious of you always wanted
that like coming from the mud coming out
the gutter yeah because I was in there I
was in the [__] gutter but I didn't
nobody respect you because they like
yeah no right come on right yeah you're
the wrong color in the gutter yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah even though he could be
but it's like dog no no [__] out of here
yeah because I I always I always really
really I think yeah that's why I mean I
think it's
I don't know it's like yeah we're not
you know I used to like be in like a
little like you know I used to hang with
the black guys and being like a little
gang it was like a shitty gang but what
was the name of y'all gang I was in the
gang too it was just called it was uh it
was called it was the same as like a
uh NFL it was called NFL and uh I know
that end stood for [__]
I don't know you sure
you were in it
I'd have to look back and see
no I was in a gang um
because he was like but our [__] was
petty though our [__] was petty too yeah
it was some [__] like for real for
real like we had bicycles yeah man we
was in some [__] called Cash and ass
yeah he's the president hey man I'm
telling you bro it was a real thing
casting ass but like we would go places
and like throw it up and be like CNA
damn it was a real thing but we was
[__] as [__] yeah like I remember we
had uh you remember the relay uh Relay
for Life [__] yeah in middle school they
make us go around the track and
everybody got to go outside and go
around the track and walk Relay for Life
so on my space at the time everybody got
online was like we gonna [__] CNA up and
we was like we're gonna [__] whatever
the other gang was up man we can't wait
to see y'all we went to the track and
walked around the [__] and we in
parallel we just kept walking the game
we never
we were [__] neither one of the gangs
never never
so imagine walking like thugs through
the whole [__] we keep looking at each
other from across the track we're just
like they're like we're gonna [__] the
ass up never we just never
we never ran into each other everybody
went inside everybody got relayed for
[__] lifetime oh damn [__] as [__]
the whole school's [__] as [__] like
what the [__] are we doing we we're
gonna fight out here like what the hell
are we doing we didn't even get close to
each other it's just stupid bro
everybody
stupid [__] man yeah that was the kind
of I think we had bicycles I remember
and we had sandwiches and [__] we were
shitty we weren't like anything real
heavy you know
but it was I missed those days man I
missed that eat that young [__] as [__]
yeah
[Laughter]
that was badass huh
y'all were doing it
I was cooking the sandwiches whose mom
made that
somebody this kid Devin's mom but little
Kenji had him a [__] Bulldog this kid
Kenji he had a bulldog all the time it
was fun man yeah we had a good time our
time was fun because everybody kind of
would go know each other you know and
sometimes we get to go to the black
church and that [__] God hey man
I didn't even grow up in a black church
but I know about it because of my
friends
bro I know about it though because of my
friends bro the Lord will [__] get
you in that [__]
you ever caught the holy ghost or not
bruh I had that dude that thanks chasing
your ass
the Holy Ghost climb out of my [__]
dicks in me bro damn dog it chased your
ass in that [__] uh-huh you'll
see Pastors in these black churches
they'll push you down if you don't go
down oh it's a big waves and [__] oh
they'll push you the [__] down you're
gonna get down in that black church
you're gonna get down
if they say that Holy Ghost hit you
[__] it's gonna hit you and if it ain't
I'm gonna miss you bro I'm telling you
they don't play that [__] yeah man is
yeah but we went to Greater Starlight
Baptist Church bro yeah and somebody
they always said somebody was dead in
the front but I don't know if they were
or not but damn
people running up there putting
everything in that [__] bro yeah that's
his real man God that was powerful man
so y'all were y'all were catholic
um I think we were we were like uh
Baptist or something six Baptists or
something like your family my family was
just like six Baptists I think we were
out there okay like your mom and all
them no my mama my dad was kind of
religious my mom wasn't real she was a
real religious she used to deliver
newspapers all the time so I get out
there on the route with her yeah
and uh
it was hectic man you know that's rough
but she had that [__] arm on her that
[__] Slinger bro oh [__] I know she
had that [__] she had that [__] on her
yeah that [__] would get out cuz you
know how'd she end up with that job like
that's such a hell of a job oh no my mom
liked to work she like to work she was
real smart but she just liked to like
she enjoyed hard work yes she enjoyed
hard labor bro
and I remember she got we were all
excited she got a Dodge Neon one time
that car you remember it or no pull it
up Dodge Neon Zach I have no [__]
clue
he did he did good there oh [__] oh cut
when we had that baby we would me and my
brother go sleep in that [__] at night
why it was nice bro why
it's crazy that you mentioned that she
enjoys her labor I got a I got a buddy
that enjoys hard labor like he he he
believes you know he he and like like in
his mind like he wouldn't want like I'll
ask him I'd be like yo would you rather
win the lottery or work at the the
factory
he's like I work at the factory for real
he said even if I even if I make it I'm
always working the factory wow and I was
like damn that's deep yeah you know that
you gotta really
I gotta be in your heart to enjoy hard
labor you know what I'm saying yeah yeah
there's nothing wrong with it you know
what I'm saying I'm not saying that at
all I think it's just
to enjoy it yeah yeah yeah I think it
does something to people that do those
types of jobs I think you just feel like
you've made some things that you created
something that feels good you got to
respect them though because [__] we need
them just as bad as he does oh yeah
um you're you put your family like in a
lot of your videos you know I see your
grandmother and stuff in your videos I
think a lot that's hilarious y'all look
really similar bro
um she's cuter yeah yeah what are you
trying to say man I'm saying she seemed
like a great woman yeah she is good um
is your was your whole family funny
where do your kind of where do you feel
like you're man your ability to be brave
kind of with humor you know where where
did any of it come from man that's crazy
you say that I believe my whole family
is hilarious man even from like my
granddad was like a jokester like he'll
go and like he was like a he was big on
pranking people like that he didn't know
in like real life you go to the store or
something my Grandma she's like a big
roaster but she only roasts like family
members and [__] like she'll talk [__]
uh my mom she's like an actress like she
always like does [__] when she's walking
around in like character [__] around
uh
my dad is just a [__] [__]
but he's
very funny because he's a dick hey
[__] yeah he's a piece of [__]
but uh yeah like you know like my whole
family like even for my brother my
sister everybody has their own type of
like
comedy but it all comes together like
ever since I was younger like everybody
supported you know me being funny and
[__] so
do you feel like does it get weird in
the funny game where people are like
kind of more Cutthroat or people like
share more do you have you found like
did you ever like get scared at first
when you were popping off that things
would get like oh [__] I gotta like keep
this close I don't know what to do here
have you ever had any trouble kind of
navigating that kind of stuff you're
saying like speaking on certain topics
or just know like even like [__] like
you know bringing people up you know
getting somebody else on board like
sharing other people's Talent like
um just because sometimes it's like even
in my career there's too much for them
is what you're saying no there's times
where I've been like [__] I got things
are going well for me yeah uh uh I'm
scared to share because will that [__]
me you know I just get you know when the
truth ends up being usually that it's
like the more people I bring in into my
own world the better it helps everybody
but I don't know it's just interesting
whenever you get busy and and I haven't
felt that yet but I I know exactly what
you're talking about when your career
starts to get busy you know I feel like
different things kind of come into your
head like how do I keep this going what
I do to make this happen is this going
to disappear very true you know you're
right though that is always the fear in
the back of your head though yeah but I
think the fear is a good thing because
it actually fuels you to keep keep going
because that fear of like falling off
that [__] will have you going for
forever bro I swear because you'll just
think keep thinking down that dark hole
of like what's happening it's gonna
happen so yeah just to figure that hell
yeah that [__] keep you motivated you
get scared to do [__] man I don't know
about that but you don't oh but you're
saying yeah I'm pretty Fearless but no
if you get in that spiral if you get
into that space I'm scared then you
operate from Scare yeah
you can't get down to hold them
um what else is it going to talk to you
about now what else oh we tried to have
mystical on but he got ended up he went
to jail yeah mystical
are you [__] kidding me they replaced
me with mystical
they brought me in I'm replacing a
mystical mystical drewski we wanted
somebody oh that name sounded like a
wizard
nah mystical dog I haven't even seen him
in a long can we pull up recent mystical
pictures get up mystical Mike
geez God damn I love myself
those old pictures of them you keep
pumping me against the wall
now he's a legend though
where is he at now can we get a he looks
healthy though man that look if that's
recent yeah I don't think he'd be
wearing bandanas oh okay that's 2003
2004. I hope he's doing well oh I don't
know that wall behind him
and anybody with a white brick wall I'm
just saying bro that [__]
[Laughter]
nobody flexes a white brick wall that's
a program yeah yeah he's in a program
right there for sure where is he at Zach
can you get some news on him let's well
yeah we've talked about this before but
he's facing charges right now he could
do life in prison because he uh are you
serious yeah he was uh messing around
with underage girls I think oh man
yeah he definitely he had won the
programs for show all right Mexico New
Orleans born rapper and the first degree
oh come on man I don't know if that's
real geez
that could be a fake site
I saw him at a car wash one time are you
serious yeah bro I was so excited what
do you have going on well he was just I
want to say it was a Mercedes
you know some of those some of those old
cats it goes one of two ways man really
they go to living regular life or they
continue to keep
the life going you just never know how
they're really living you know some
people make more than others yeah people
not getting those back end checks the
one I know huh sad but no it's good to
hear that he was he was in a Mercedes
yeah it was like when they had that guy
from The Cosby Show that didn't make you
know they put him out a few years ago
somebody was putting him on blasted he
wasn't making him he's working at like a
grocery store oh yeah I've seen that
[__] maybe somebody else [__] up
though yeah because it was like bro why
are y'all embarrassing this dude and
Waters in that dude why isn't that why
is that a bad thing though that he's
working you know what I'm saying they're
making it seem like this is the worst in
the world agree and why doesn't he have
any extra money that dude if I know him
from my whole childhood he should have
some sort of stake in what he was a part
of
you know Jeffrey Owens yeah they're busy
it's just such a dangerous business man
I think it's gotten better yeah because
people fight for more like rights to own
things like dang dude for like a lot of
it it was like the people owned
everything that's crazy
people yeah they they definitely owning
everything for sure you gotta you gotta
own your own stuff man you got your own
production company and all that yeah
yeah that's good yeah like you know your
own like corporations and all that stuff
yeah yeah same be smart don't start
kick the habit
put it out before it puts you out all
phrases we've heard a hundred times yet
we still continue to have bad habits
our sponsor fume is on a mission to
accelerate Humanity's breakup from the
bad habits that consume far too many of
us
fume is a natural diffusive device that
uses plants and Behavioral Science to
help you trade out your negative habit
for a positive one
fume is not a vape it's a non-electric
device designed to transform your
negative habits that's right instead of
PODS filled with potentially harmful
chemicals like a vape fume uses cores
infused with plants like peppermint and
cinnamon for delicious natural flavors
with an adjustable airflow dial and a
magnetic end cap your fingers will
always have something to do
head to trifum.com and use code Theo to
save 10 percent off the easiest way to
stop a bad habit is to switch to a
positive one and fume is designed
perfectly to do just that it's fumes
goal to make switching easy and even
enjoyable they have thousands of five
star reviews from people just like you
who's successfully switched when other
Solutions just didn't work head to
trifum.com and use code Theo to save 10
off when you get the journey pack today
the journey pack comes with three unique
flavors and the new version 2 fume to
help kick start your positive habits
that's try f u m.com and use code Theo
to save an additional 10 off your order
today
um do you have like a mentor that you
use in businesses and stuff like that do
you just rely mostly with your agents
how do you work on that kind of stuff
you know I don't I mean the agents are
only going to help but so much you know
they're there for like to fall back on
but honestly you got to get out here and
that work man you gotta you gotta meet
these people these people and build good
relationships with them for real because
there ain't nobody looking to help you
ain't nobody just gonna give it to you
you know and your agents are there to
like help from that like they'll see you
doing some [__] and maybe they could put
the pieces together behind the scenes
that are already working somewhere else
but they can also get you opportunities
but if you want the agents to work best
for you
always try to figure out [__] on your
own while they're working on the side on
some [__] yeah I've seen that work best
for me with you know just with
commercial work and stuff just building
good relationships with people bro for
real do you have like mentors that you
talk to about stuff or is it kind of
just general
I think I have good friends that are
like famous that I don't like
yeah I won't even like post
conversations or nothing yeah you know
like honestly where I've had
conversations with some of the
biggest people and about like [__] that
I may go through or or what I'm what I
may look forward to seeing soon yeah
there's some people out there that that
uh uh I look up to that have helped out
for sure
hell yeah
man so many people love you yeah yeah
yeah that's crazy thankful for real yeah
bro remember when y'all got lost at the
LSU and y'all went out there and we were
praying for y'all they left Darius
they left Darius bro
yeah the PJ took out without him you
didn't give a [__] you had your feet up
just like that
you said yo man where's that black guy
y'all were with that tall black guy you
know I don't give a [__] you popping
peanuts in the back of the [__] [__]
he didn't give a [__] bro that wasn't me
yeah you can give a [__] you didn't
remember his name like yo that tall
black guy you were with man he didn't
get on the PJ with us
[__] out of here dog piece of [__] bro
that wasn't me bro that was a good time
though I can't lie that was a great time
and that's right they treated us well we
pulled up at LSU oh man they had jerseys
for us man we went to the casino we lost
[__] every dollar yeah
you got about it quick you did well
because yeah
I was so sad yeah yeah I said I'm gonna
either steal or I'm a [__] leave
you're not a big gambling God I don't
like to risk it bro yeah yeah I don't
like to risk it bro if I make that
dollar you gotta take risk to make that
money though man we lost like 90 000 bro
okay
maybe I'm not the best financial guy to
be talking well I'm just saying man at
that point at that point it's getting
stupid
let's let's be financially smart about
it that's h r black at that point dog
I'm [__] okay
I got stupid it got stupid bro we gotta
roll again I'm [__] you're rolling out
this [__] these dice can [__] stay
by themselves man bro damn bro nah we
that's that's some new [__] that we've
been getting into we actually enjoy
playing back her up oh y'all dude is
like a bad addiction to me and the Gang
right now like bro everybody is on it
like we literally take me through the
game man I want people to know your gang
is because this is one thing that really
was I thought I was gonna say gang
because [__] okay handing out Rico's
like no tomorrow group of positive young
men yeah
but this is one thing that was really
awesome about meeting you first of all I
didn't know you was going to be there
and they pull up and they opened up the
Sprinter and drewski's right there I'm
just sitting there looking at you yeah
and he was there and I think he was like
sleeping or awake or just chilling
because it had been a long day yeah yeah
yeah and I'm like oh [__] and it was
dark in there remember and I had to get
in there and I was like oh [__] you had
no clue what's going on oh bro and then
I get in the back and there's even more
like kind of hits
they have [__] a brother on top of a
brother it's a Brotherhood
right one dude opened his mouth and
another mother what up
so it was brother the hot dog in the
door closing I was just [__] in the
dark man and uh but your friends bro
they're [__] it's yeah it's like
being on a it's almost like being at on
a it's like you're watching a sitcom all
the time bro everybody's funny in their
own way for real bro honestly like
everybody has their own role and like
you know and and with employing them has
come even more funny ventures of what
everybody does and like just going on
trips and it's just it's amazing bro
like it's fun doing all this stuff
there's great stuff with your friends or
forever and let's go through them
because first you got the young fella
the little Blondie and uh and he's
Jamaican right yeah the short ones yeah
that's that's bacon oh he isn't he's
African he's Liberian oh he's like beer
that's so damn bro solo well he's a damn
liability
yeah
and dog he'll doze off yeah yeah he'll
doze off yeah
Goldilocks are sleeping
you know what's so funny he's a big
sleeper bro like no bro don't leave him
by a train track that [__] he'll
[__] catch the first car coming bro
that dude
yo but you've never been to Baton Rouge
so yeah yeah bro and he was wearing all
LSU [__] yeah
LSU thong on it [__] like he had a fish
net with him he had a [__] like a
pole with a net on it
bro he was only excited to get that he
was suicide don't even got his cousin
who's Chauncey Cinco oh yeah now quiet
but deadly you know yeah Chelsea you
don't know he's got that uh yeah you
don't know if he's you know where he
kind of he if he was in like a uh
if you've been in a center or whatever
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you know he
seemed a little bit you've been in the
program somewhere yeah yeah he
definitely got some [__] you know he
got that bite to him you see him but he
quiet though but he got it to him though
he he'll laugh with you but he ain't too
much ain't too much that it's gonna be
funny yeah like he might be haunted a
little yeah yeah yeah you know like he
got he got demons that he deal with
though you know you know yeah [__] from
the past man but he's he's actually one
of he's a very funny guy behind behind
Soul he's probably like the second yeah
and he dresses also he'll dress like a
ninja a lot of times yeah so he comes in
down [__] that dude a do-ragon
everything
he's gonna see his face too much man
yeah so he [__] hidden bro he hiding
in place man yeah yeah and then you got
the big dog big Darius man Darius Darius
dog these are goofy you know we we hired
uh there's a security at first oh yeah
we went to a party and he was like
[__] nanaying with girls across the
club and I'm like yo I go you're
supposed to be securing this [__]
section over here and he's like on Molly
putting [__] up his butt you know with
white girls
Bottom Jeans all that [__] twerking
and [__] and like he's just such a
Goofer like yo [__] it we're just gonna
have this guy around as a [__]
another comedian because he's a damn
goofy like why the hell did we think
we're gonna have a security he's a nut
bro you see he got left in Louisiana
like who the [__] gets left on a trip in
your hotel room we get up like the
bruh yeah man yeah he's awesome man we
still got some other members that you
haven't met there oh really yeah they
stay at the house in uh in Atlanta so
you got to meet them too man it's
yeah whole team is is
yeah because it was fun man when I left
you guys I was like man I missed that
group that group yeah it was just like
we got to do that again we definitely
there's just always a chance to laugh
with y'all like there's never a point
where you couldn't somebody's not
ripping on everybody [__] up [__] oh
yeah totally yeah
I agree that was really perfect man that
trip that trip honestly we got to do
that again especially with Todd too Todd
oh yeah yeah hanging at Todd is wild man
y'all went uh Legend bro y'all went to
the National Championship yeah we went
to NCAA Championship how was it it was
great uh Michael Rubin was there he was
in like the section right next to us I
don't know Michael Rubin the billionaire
oh really yeah you know little baby said
I get all my advice from Mike ruber
uh-uh you know listen a little baby I
don't yeah that's why I'm on it I will I
will listen yeah you take a peek at that
but not bring him up a little baby let's
see him you you know uh Michael Rubin
had the uh the all-white party with all
the celebrities went out there and it
was he had a huge birthday party
um I thought uh Puff Daddy had that
party
little baby you know little baby nice
guy yeah great guy little baby yeah
little baby yeah yeah people love him
yeah yeah a lot of people love him for
real people always hear him and who shot
what's her name who was that guy wait
what
who shot the stallion
you know what I'm talking about
Google it Zachary
who shot the stallion yeah
baby hey let's get some AC going in this
house
blast we boiling in this [__] man I'll
quit in a few minutes man [__] what
about this kind of [__] man do you think
what do you think when you look like
because you make a lot of videos online
what kind of videos do you watch online
do you watch because these are these are
folks let's play it up Zach these are
folks right here at IHOP that like to go
in bro something about syrup makes
people want to [__] fight yeah this
is a fight at an IHOP that we were
watching before anything on Reddit is
literally not trusted yeah this could be
actors bro
[Music]
people still Scream the world
one dude I guess
oh damn it takes forever to set those
tables too bro yeah dude
I feel bad for whoever did that [__]
that's not him they flip my shits upside
down oh my God
damn bro winner you ever work anywhere
good yeah man I actually uh I worked at
Red Lobster I worked no Outback
Steakhouse yeah yeah I worked at [__]
Movie Tavern oh really what is it was I
was uh movie time was like a uh like you
serve people at the movies I was I was a
food Runner there dang I hated that [__]
you did oh man
[__] I used to have to like make
popcorn and [__] like
yeah man those those are the good old
days though boys you know like
[__] we look back on and just be like
thank God all right I ain't being at
Movie Tavern yeah I've never been in a
movie tab yeah Movie Tavern is good it's
a great place to it is no not a great
place to work but yeah yeah
have you ever been to Sea World no no no
never been hmm
I know a lot of people I actually
watched the documentary on Sea World
what was it now they were um what's it
called Zach Blackfish yeah yeah what is
it yeah it's about like how they the
whole [__] kills in captivity yeah
it's how they treat black fish dude
that's [__] unreal bro is that what
it's about
yeah yeah
that is yeah it's called Blackfish damn
bro see
yeah man
it's a great documentary though and I
was watching it and it's like
them whales was [__] those people up
though really so they fought back yeah
the whales was [__] them I think it
killed it killed a good couple people
yeah man that [__] that [__] got deep it
got dark man damn I don't play that [__]
yeah I don't know if I I mean I never
really had any issues with fish or
anything
um or I I guess I mean I have I don't
know I've been deep sea fishing I didn't
really love it yeah but I you know I
like I wouldn't I would maybe go again I
guess
um
but I know some some Adventures like
that where it's a bunch of men out there
yeah and they all drank and it just like
I don't know you know I always wanted to
go uh feed the [__] pigs and [__]
yeah out there and um wherever that
Georgia or whatever no not what the [__]
no I'm like a
foreign country where they feed the pigs
in the water and [__] oh damn oh like
Barbados or something yeah yeah one of
those one of those places yeah yeah
really [__] off I just went I was in
Mexico and I got to meet Wiz Khalifa and
then I never met him before you ever met
him no he was cool we got to go horse if
I did I don't remember I don't think I
met Wiz Khalifa ever we got to go
horseback riding really yeah damn it was
fun man I was he as a person like he's
chill nicest dude his whole family was
there
Sherry Sherry and LT nah I didn't I
should have but I got high that's kind
of like even just smelling them being
around yeah yeah I was [__] yeah if
he was in a room [__] staying by
the van
come on
but uh yeah his sister was there she's
pretty yeah um it was fun we had a good
time yeah yeah hey watch you throw that
coming in on this you were just with his
whole family his sister was that she
would you think he would allow you to
date assistant
I think he might allow me for real yeah
I think I was up he was letting me all
flirting so I don't know we weren't
flirting I mean I don't I mean I don't
think we were flirting I I I I I I was
also trying to just like be on a
vacation where I was not doing nothing
and they were doing like a lot of
activities so some days I would not do
the activities yeah
what do you think like do you want to
make TV shows I mean I know you're
already making some stuff but do you
want to do like do you see yourself
having like a certain route in your
business do you just kind of love where
you're at and everything's great that
too I mean I'm I'm at a point where I
love where I'm at and everything is
great but also I have so much [__] that
I want to accomplish in that I literally
battle with every night in my mind of
like why it's not done yet you know so
yeah there's a lot of [__] I want to do
like TV movies you know uh this tour
just to have under my belt and just be
like yo let's do more of it you know and
just to you know you know sometimes you
just gotta I have to remind myself to
just live in the moment remember that
this is enjoy the process but it's hard
when you really have all this stuff and
your goals and [__] and you see the
people you look up to have already
accomplished and you're like all right I
just want to get there I want to get
there I want to get there so I just had
to remind myself just live in a moment
man so that's what I'm dealing with
right now but everything's great you
know I can't complain yeah taking care
of the whole family you know yeah yeah
so we trying to we're trying to do this
[__] for a long time was there something
nice that you bought for yourself or for
a family member when you started to have
some success
um
I retired my mom gang baby
um Mom done huh did she pick up any new
habits because sometimes that's a risk
about retiring your mom bro next thing
you know I'm expenses
it's fairly new it's fairly new right
now like it's only been like a month so
we I haven't seen nothing yet that would
be you know too crazy it's only been a
month so we'll see where it takes us but
yeah no man that'd be a good show
retired miles and it's like people that
were able to retire their mother and
then that first [__] they just start
Walling up first everywhere I go on a
[__] tour yeah they [__] Delonte
West they're doing all kind of [__] man
they [__] getting out there you know
that's the kind of [__] that I really
get it yeah man because
um do you like the New Orleans Pelicans
or you don't uh I actually played with
them on 2K uh-uh you didn't swear hell
yeah nice I like um CJ McCollum a lot
yeah yeah yeah people love him yeah yeah
I like his [__] man he's a good player
yeah I liked him back when he was with
um what's he called he was a Trailblazer
hell of a shooter yeah but uh yeah I'm
not like a big fan of watching them on
TV though I just play with them because
they're good as [__] and too good yeah
you don't play two no games no I would
like to get on there more often yeah but
I just haven't done it I mean I bought
the game I think but I haven't played it
yeah yeah so I gotta get on there but I
will I'll be forgetting you know you got
such a young face man I'd be getting out
how old you are man if I can get no bro
yeah man the Lord looking for me cut no
we out here though
how old are you bro
42.2 [__] gonna die though no that's
I gotta get this you in a good you're in
a good place though you know like 42 is
like
you're in a solid yo you're like yeah
[__] right yeah take your hand bro
[Laughter]
42 42 is actually a good age like it's
in the it's in the middle you're not 50
you're not 60. you know what I'm saying
like you're you're Jackie Robinson isn't
it yeah let's go let's go boy four two
dog gang son is another rapper I don't
know God bro 442 Doug demon home baby
yeah demon home [__] yeah look at this
dude 4-2 Doug
Magano oh yeah yeah and what happened he
got shot no he didn't get shot well
because he's short I don't know I
thought he's in a wheelchair now he's
short of [__] are we 42. pull up the
basketball picture right there the one
in the middle at the top yeah
yeah he's no he's really four too oh
dang Doug coming up yeah wow
yeah man [__] I want to meet him
you met him no I ain't meet him yet nah
oh do you ever meet ooh kill him that
guy who kill him
loterio yeah I ain't never meeting him
nah he lost weight though little mine
bro sometimes when people lose weight
it's not the same person bro
so explain this explain yourself facts
man so I used to work on a uh I used to
work on my buddy's Farm my buddy's farm
for like two years right and so they
completely not the same person no more
well look they had a man that came to
clean the pool and so one year I'd seen
him for a couple years bro big dude
overalls just [__]
just [__] what the [__]
just damn bro like you knew he said yeah
you knew he snored at night yeah yeah
and bruh yeah he [__] one year he got
his tubes tied or whatever and then he
came to clean the pool one day and I'm
sitting out there and he keep looking at
me and I'm like who in the [__] is this
dude bro I thought he was like a pervert
ah so I'm chilling and [__] making
sure I'm covered up and uh and then I
realized it's the same dude he had the
surgery bro and I started talking to him
and he just was totally different I
didn't like him
do change his life for the better and
you didn't like him oh yeah I don't like
change so you liked it when he was
injected like a [__] turkey blowing
up he's about to pop out there in the
pool
I don't like change bruh yeah yeah I get
it I get it no I I've heard that a lot
though you know some people lose too
much weight like some people they lose
weight and be like okay that was good
you needed that and then some people
would be like Yay man
you're losing a little bit of a Little
Neck weight you know
like Al Roker when he lost a lot
remember yeah yeah
[__] got weird she got wonky a little
bit didn't it I thought so after he had
that [__] gobble on him I thought
somebody gonna shoot him in November
you know I'm saying yeah that [__]
yeah
look I'm gonna say this bro he looked
like he started recruiting for the uh
but see he did it at a bad age man he
waited too a little too late bro he was
getting so fat his eyes was going bad
dang cuz he was doing bad dog look at
him bro
oh damn look at him on the right left
he needed that though I'm proud of that
boy
yeah I am too bro yeah hell yeah yeah
cause that's well at a certain point
it's like what you're saying sometimes
people are just like uh
you enjoy them more
or at seeing them this way and it's too
weird for you to look at them that way I
get it and it really is a me thing I
think it had nothing to do with them
yeah but
um what else you got one more news clip
exactly we can look at and then we'll
let drusky get on I know he had a long
day man
you know you could tell I'm tired of
spot no I just know you've had a long
day yeah I'm just so glad you came man
oh yeah I actually wanted to do this I
told my team I said [__] yeah I I well
actually I hit you too I know yeah we
talked about a resource I really wanted
to do thank you bro thank you it's a
blessing man yeah
yeah uh what else we got Zachary
I'm calling him Zack to Zach I'm finding
this video we watch y'all grew up
together you and Zach
how do you know Zachary good guy though
we met one years ago huh
yeah like a year ago I came around
started doing video
I came around started [__] him on
video you have only fans of counter no
nah man I tend to uh well I mean if if
you if we're talking about just to watch
yeah I don't post anything on there but
you know some some of those girls on
there you'd be like I just want to see
what she's talking about yeah yeah so I
definitely I gotta I got a peek in one
just to see what you know some of them
talking about it gets scary though I'll
be on you know and then I don't know I
got on there and then I immediately
deleted I get all nervous wow because
you feel like people gonna know who you
are I feel like at some point that is so
weird man you know I get on there and
like you can even like it's weird people
can even Trace back how you texted on
this right yeah so I try to watch out
sometimes I like to misspell [__] on
purpose I'm like [__] you ain't gonna
notice it's me I'm texting you in real
life on my phone so if I if I put too
many commas and periods where I'd put
them you gonna know who the [__] I am
behind this [__] 15.
[Laughter]
you ain't gonna catch me I'm spelling
all types all types of [__] wrong
I'm spelling that as that d-a-t
they talk with somebody
they think they talking to some [__]
ghetto ass dude I'm telling you you
gotta switch it up
that many asses bro what get on a
problem bro
oh say
but dude it is true I'll be like what's
up with good booty images
my friend
oh dude 100 right
because I'm only going on a date gotta
be a completely different person
especially when you're just like looking
like you just wanted to see you know
there's certain girls that you talk to
on a you know yeah trying to figure out
what's going on you know can people see
you're a good [__] you know [__] like
that bro
like a top hat at the end bro you know
what I'm saying
foreign
[Laughter]
oh [__] bro that is so funny because I
didn't think anybody else thought like
me when I get on there because I
literally just just look at just
checking [__] out
oh
you're sick man damn right you are
we in the same boat we're in the same
boat man and uh
I'm happy to be in it with you let's
look at one more video man what we got
this is a couple white guys got real
drunk at a frat party and branded
themselves
what is this
oh I know what this is It's branding oh
I didn't think we're looking at this oh
this is a fraternity
that's a car part oh my God they're
going through his chest yo they
shouldn't have gone that that deep
where's this at a Pep Boys I should have
been took it out oh oh [__]
yo yo he went down to his like heart oh
damn bro look at this video bro he went
into like his heart
[Laughter]
they go
oh and it's still in there bruh
that's like that thing at the Mexican
restaurant that you order bro that's
like that fancy yeah
my God they even put some onions on that
crazy bro God because that's uh that's
something they do at a lot of the black
fraternities right yeah yeah how do they
do it for Q dogs they do the same thing
but you know you're only supposed to tap
it uh-uh you tap it on there and you
release it because it's already gonna do
it's already going to burn the skin as
with a quick tap
what the [__] was that dug it in there
they literally almost got to his heart
dang good they got some [__]
see you gotta make yo have they lost
their phone I guess so why do you have
that I want to show you a real video of
how it's supposed to be bro that is
insane oh bro
yo it's boring like a steaming it's
smoking look how much it raises off his
skin though yeah
and then they sprayed hand sanitizer on
that [__]
show me the one show me the cute dog and
I want to see how they do it because
I've seen this on a lot of guys see if
you can pull it up too Zachary try to
pull up Q Dog branding
a real a real one and what does it mean
so this is something that happens in a
lot of black projects I've seen it on a
lot of black men yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and it's like regular like that's
some [__] they usually do damn
yeah man
oh there it is right there oh yeah he
must be a general huh yeah but see the
the this [__] it already heals up like
that I've never seen them go as deep as
they just did
well and to the other dude's skin wow
hit that picture right down in the
Middle with everybody's shirt off no
that one right under it
yeah they got it done to their chest oh
and they have the Hat they have the uh
yeah
what's the sound they made uh
two dogs man and so Q Dog means what
fraternity do you know uh they eat [__]
oh yeah that's what they should do
there's some other ones that do other
[__] but they he does they should eat
[__] damn solid they big on that yeah
they big on that there and they're
eating [__] [__] down yeah maybe Q
dog's big on that it's a cappers do
something else but cute dogs that's what
they do
what what do they do any philanthropy or
something
else I mean there's other stuff there's
other stuff right but that's there yeah
they thing is that that's like a
recreation yeah
Drewsky man brother bro thank you so
much man really thank you brother yeah
oh you wanna come and do something I
know uh you gotta come out to the show
man I wanna oh I want to come to the
show open up one of the nights
hey man I got white people in the crowd
they have black people everybody
actually I bet you got a pretty good mix
crowd yeah I got a good I got a good
mixed crowd that's true yeah yeah maybe
so man let me think about some good
materials I could have for them dang bro
come on
don't come in there cripping it up man
whatever the [__] you do don't come in
there today
he's lying to you
hear me
thank you so much man best of luck on
the tour we'll put a link where you can
get all the tickets is it already sold
out can people get tickets okay Batman
and I'll share it on my socials too man
and uh thank you so much man what his
attitude shows too Los Angeles and San
Diego Batman yeah well uh take care of
your game man I look forward to seeing
you guys again
now I'm just floating on the breeze and
I feel I'm falling like these leaves I
must be
the Cornerstone
I reached that ground I'll share this
piece of mine I found I can feel it in
my bones
gonna take